plusieurs qualifient la banlieue de
ville dortoir et pourtant le lieutenant
daniel guérin qui cumule 25 années
d'expérience à la police de laval nous
servira de guide cette nuit aussitôt
embarqué déjà un appel mais dirigée sur
l'appel ou est ce que les jeunes futurs
débats
on y chante bien mais très cher de voir
ce soir le plaignant encore en visuel
les jeunes qui pâturent et les voitures
pour passer les détails mineurs mais
pour les citoyens c'est un événement
quelqu'un vienne me voir faire pâturer
sa voiture c'est la sécurité non
seulement qu est ce qui est arrivé
notre soirée se poursuit arrêt devant un
établissement licencié du secteur
centropolis ici l'escouade équinoxe et
en actions sept policiers spécialisés
pour traquer le crime organisé les
visages des policiers ont été masquées
car leur efficacité est directement liée
à leur anonymat été reconnus et
identifiés
donc nous comptions un très beau
policiers
dans le quartier industriel à quelques
pas d'un salon de massage
le lieutenant guérin nous emmène
patrouille et devint local de
motocyclistes rapidement nous sommes
accueillis par trois d'entre eux fiers
d'arborer leurs vestes avec une taxe des
patriots riders
jonathan dulac et d'arbustes ainsi dale
puis vous avez donné des informations
puis ça nous faisait presque deux ans
dotées on éteint leurs tarifs c'est
exactement le cas d'abord au début c'est
bon ap la police quelque chose dans mon
fils parle de sunrise est un club
amateur en bonne et due forme
et puis nous policiers avec des
informations pour justement déterminer
le rôle de ces individus en savoir et ce
qu'ils jouent un rôle je dirais dans la
criminalité de laval
ensuite un appel pour un suspect armé
aux abords du métro montmorency
mais voyez quelque chose les gens qui
sont six frères et aussi pour une
surveillance d'ims possibles agresseurs
sexuels déjà 23h30 et l'équipe de nuit
s'apprête à prendre le relais le
lieutenant jean fait le suivi avec ses
troupes
il les informe des dossiers qui
nécessiteront un suivi durant leur quart
de travail
enlèvement séquestration
cinq personnes on est sur le boulevard
saint-martin ouest
il ya eu un appel il y aurait eu un vol
dans une bijouterie on sait pas pour
combien et ce qui est particulier c'est
que le suspect serait peut-être toujours
à l'intérieur donc les policiers sont à
sa recherche
puis une fois en italie sud
armée poids les policiers prennent cette
invention sérieux parce qu'un groupe de
voleurs ciblent des commerces de luxe en
moins de deux minutes ils auront quitté
avec leur butin bisous et alcool sont
leurs cibles préférées celle qui est la
plus proche
ok je pense qu'il doit encore c'est
l'appui stand amende
une vague de vols de plusieurs milliers
de dollars frappe laval un autre dossier
chaud des combats tient beaucoup de dos
et de cruauté envers les animaux
c'est plutôt rare mais un gros par
n'organiserait sur le territoire les
chiens retrouvés ont même dû être
euthanasiés et puis stade aussi le qu'on
aimerait mettre un terme et pas d'un
épicier des combats cente retour de
laval on veut que on veut que ça cesse
contre lequel des foules
pour nous c'est un retour au poste mais
voici la liste des appels auxquels les
autres équipes ont répondu au cours de
la nuit
laval ville dortoir dites vous